madame monsieur bonsoir seule une sorte
de folie et d'hystérie collective semble
pouvoir expliquer le carnage qui s'est
déroulé dans deux petits villages suisse
à quelques dizaines de kilomètres de
genève de drame presque simultanément
dans des chalets à cherry et à salvan
les adeptes d'une secte l'ordre du
temple solaire se sont suicidés l'anc
est sur place d' antoine cormery et
pierre moscovitch 23 corps alignés dans
le jardin de la ferme de la rochette dix
hommes 12 femmes et un enfant de dix ans
c'est le macabre bilan de la nuit dans
le petit village de chéri à une
trentaine de kilomètres de fribourg en
suisse romande
tout a commencé aux alentours de minuit
par un violent incendie les pompiers
dépêchés sur place sont alors trouvés
dans une chambre le propriétaire de la
ferme un homme de 70 ans ils étaient
allongés morts
la tête prise dans un sac en plastique
fermé par un cordon
mais ce n'est qu'à l'aube que les
inspecteurs de police suspectant la
présence d'autres personnes dans la
ferme ont inspecté le sous-sol épargnés
par les flammes
c'est là qu'ils ont découvert une
ouverture secret encore et c'est là
qu'on a trouvé les 22 personnes est un
dieu en forme d'orange dans la pièce qui
semble être l'église
certains des corps retrouvé était
revêtue de cap de couleur 20 des 23
corps portaient des traces de balles
principalement dans le crâne presque
tous avaient un sac plastique sur la
tête
en fouillant le sous-sol les inspecteurs
ont retrouvé dans la chapelle de
nombreux objets de culte
nul doute que la ferme était un
important lieu de réunion pour cette
secte de l'ordre tradition solaire un
lieu de réunion que les membres de la
secte ont voulu faire disparaître après
leur suicide collectif avec un
dispositif de mise à feu extrêmement
perfectionnés rien pourtant dans ce
village ne laissait présager le drame
jusqu'ici les gens qui étaient dans
cette ferme oui et alors qu'elles
apprennent qu'à la pression
très bon à la pression c'était très
sympa très gentil j'ai eu l'occasion de
discuter avec les cinq vraiment très
très sympa et vous imaginiez qui a une
secte dans cette ferme pas du tout alors
non même en discutant en parlant avec
eux il ne s'est vraiment pas supposer sa
portée d'une secte au sud à 200 km de là
le scénario s'est reproduit presque à
l'identique 25 corps carbonisés ont été
retirés des décombres de deux chalets
dans le village de salvan dans le valais
un troisième chalet qui a également
brûlé la nuit dernière n'a pas encore
été explorées complètement à cause des
risques d'effondrement
là encore un savant système de mise à
feu avaient été installés
l'identification des corps sera très
difficile dans le deuxième chapeau qui a
été cordial à demain carbonisé on n'a
pas de on va pas de tout cas d'offre on
sait qu'à des cadors mais on ne peut pas
dire ce que ceux des enfants on ne peut
pas dire la police suisse a lancé un
appel à témoins pour que les familles se
manifeste et permettre rapidement
l'identification des corps une
identification rendu plus facile à
cherry grâce à des papiers retrouvés sur
place
parmi ces papiers sainte carte
d'identité appartenant à des
ressortissants français
nous nous retrouvons antoine quant aux
rives donc l'un de nos envoyés spéciaux
en direct de shérif bon soir antoine on
vient de voir dans votre sujet que
apparemment cette opération avait été
minutieusement préparée est ce que l'on
en sait un peu plus ce soir sur les
conditions dans lesquelles a été
organisé ce suicide collectif
c'est vrai qu'elle a été minutieusement
préparé les enquêteurs ont retrouvé tout
un système de mise à feu dans ce chalet
un système qui a en partie fonctionné
car il y avait une panne de courant dans
le village ces jours ci c'est ce qui
explique que le système n'est pas
fonctionné mieux que ça mais certaines
bonbonnes de gaz n'ont pas explosé en
revanche tout était relié à un système
téléphonique extrêmement pointue et
c'est vraisemblablement l'oeuvre de deux
professionnels qui avait travaillé sur
sur ce système de mise à feu
vraisemblablement pour faire disparaître
complètement
ce chalet l'anc est aujourd'hui
s'oriente aussi vers un certain nombre
de personnes qui ont habité ce chalet
qui en sont partis les enquêteurs on
interroge maintenant ce moment même
une personne un suisse qui qui a habité
ce chalet pendant pendant de longues
années avant de divorcer d'une femme qui
est toujours ici
est ce que l'on sait antoine si le chef
de cette secte le chef présumé on parle
d'un québécois d'une quarantaine
d'années et parmi les victimes
retrouvées
alors ce que l'on sait c'est que les
victimes de cette secte était un peu
habillée en fonction de leur statut dans
la secte est effectivement on a retrouvé
quelqu'un qui portait une cape noire et
qui semble être l'apanage d'un chef
mais pour l'instant on n'a aucune
précision sur les identités précise on
sait simplement que parmi les victimes
il y aurait cinq français ont en tout
cas retrouvé cinq cartes d'identité
française
merci antoine pour ces précisions on
imagine assez facilement la stupéfaction
et l'émotion des habitants de cette
région du valle
apparemment les habitants connaissaient
les activités de certains membres de
cette secte mais jamais rien ne leur
père leur aurait permis pardon
d'imaginer le drame qui allait se nouer
en quête de notre deuxième équipe
d'envoyés spéciaux eric lemasson et jean
corps la police cantonale du valais a
vite découvert le système de mise à feu
des chalets une minuterie relié à une
résistance électrique qui a chauffé des
allumettes les allumettes sont tombés
dans des flaques d'essence
ici dans cette annexe qui servait
apparemment de chapelle le système n'a
pas fonctionné
c'est dans ce chalet au lieu dit la
fontaine est ce que le feu a pris en
première mais ce soir on commençait tout
juste à fouiller les décombres à la
recherche d'éventuels autres cadavres
un peu plus bas les deux autres chalets
dévasté des cadavres dans chaque pièce
hommes femmes enfants 25 hors asphyxie
empoisonnement ou arme à feu les
policiers ne savent pas encore quelles
sont les causes des décès les médecins
légistes ne sont pas assez nombreux face
à cette hécatombe dans le village de
salvan c'est la consternation personne
ne savait qu'une secte pouvait se réunir
au village
la plupart étaient là dernièrement et
d'après ce que j'ai pu savoir les
locations était terminé ce samedi donc
les gens s'apprêtait à partir j'ai
d'ailleurs eu d'avis rendu moi même dans
ses appartements pour constater que les
valises étaient bouclés et que les gens
fassent tout était prêt comme si les
gens allaient partir est ce que vous
avez eu l'impression qu'ils avaient une
sorte de rassemblement justement ces
derniers temps dans ces chalets les
derniers temps ces quelques derniers
jours peut-être je m'en suis d'ailleurs
inquiété auprès de la police qui a je
crois a mené une petite enquête parce
qu'il y avait pas mal de va-et-vient de
voitures de location de grosses voitures
les victimes avaient loué cinq à six
appartements dans la commune quant aux
deux chalets où s'est produit le drame
l'un appartenait à un certain 10 membres
ou l'autre dit on à luc jouret le
fondateur de l'ordre du temple du soleil
eric lemasson notre deuxième envoyé
spécial et en direct donc de ce deuxième
village de village de salvan eric c'est
toujours l'incrédulité j'imagine la
consternation qui domine ce soir dans la
population
oui etienne salvan vous savez c'est un
petit village de 1200 habitants c'est
une petite station on y fait du ski
juste un peu plus haut ici l'hiver et on
y fait du canyoning
l'été c'est donc une petite station qui
est consterné ce soir personne
évidemment ne pouvait se douter qu'un
tel drame pouvait se produire ici les
habitants ne connaissais pas vraiment
les gens qui sont morts dans ces chalets
simplement certains certains visages
étaient connus on les croisait dans les
commerces
mais dit-on ici il ne se mêlait pas
vraiment aux activités de la de la
commune du village les fêtes par exemple
qui ont lieu chaque été ici ces
personnes ni venez pas ici le village cd
tête haute
étonnamment pardon calme ce soir les
gens sont rentrés chez eux
il ya juste simplement le va et vient
des corbillards des policiers est
également des journalistes qui sont très
nombreux voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire
etienne ce soir ici à salvan merci eric
alors l'ordre du temple solaire était
apparemment une secte considéré comme
marginal en suisse
son chef son gourou était un homme de 46
ans d'origine québécoise
philippe boisserie en enquêtant a
retrouvé des familles de français qui à
un moment de leur vie ont partagé les
activités de cette secte celle incendie
apparemment banale de cette maison près
de montréal
hier peu avant les drames de cherry et
des granges qui a fourni la clé de cette
folie mortels propriétaire des lieux luc
jouret médecin homéopathe de 46 ans mais
aussi fondateur d'une secte l'ordre du
temple du soleil
l'homme utilisait souvent sa première
qualité pour attirer ces recrues
gilberte delorme le sait trop bien elle
qui lutte contre les sectes a souvent
croisé dans sa bretagne les chemins de
luc jouret sous les affiches de ces
conférences se cacher un redoutable
manière dames c'est une personne
dangereuse parce qu'elle est
remarquablement intelligente et elle a
un pouvoir psychique sur les gens halak
risque remarquable et nous avons
rencontré une fois une personne qui même
prévenu nous a dit vous me l'aviez dit
mais j'aurais jamais cru que j'aurais pu
succomber au psychisme et au rayonnement
de cette activité en france au canada en
suisse
ils recrutent si possible des cadres des
médecins des gens d'un bon niveau
à montréal il arrivera même infiltrer
l'encadrement de cette société hydro
québec où l'on a découvert l'an dernier
un trafic d'armes
car le gourou préparer aussi la fin du
monde une mission qui visiblement coûter
cher et projets
après de construire l'offre de surpris
que vous voulez la ferme écologique au
canada avec un punk air où les gens
devaient du monde luc jouret n'aura donc
pas réussi sa mission éviter
l'apocalypse pour bon nombre de ses
membres dans sa maison canadienne deux
autres cadavres ont été découverts pour
l'instant non identifié certains
craignent que le gourou puisse encore
nuire à tâche des enquêteurs n'est pas
beaucoup plus facile même si l'on
s'oriente vers la thèse du suicide
collectif pour expliquer la mort des 48
membres de la secte du temple solaire
certains d'entre eux cependant aurait
été drogué un départ dans l'au-delà
marquée par une hystérie collective au
cours de laquelle il aurait même sabler
le champagne
l'enquète dans le village de chez reed
antoine cormery et pierre moscovici un
long couloir des murs tendu de satin
rouge
c'est dans ce décor baroque que la secte
tenait ces séances secrètes dans le
sous-sol de la ferme de la rochette a
chéri c'est dans ce même décor où
trônent au centre une rose d'argent
symbole du mouvement que les policiers
ont découvert hier matin les 22 corps
des membres de la secte 19 étaient
allongés en cercle étroit se tenait dans
cette petite salle recouvertes de
miroirs un décor épargné par une
défaillance du système de mise à feu qui
confirme toute l'importance de ce lieu
de prière dans l'organigramme de la
secte mais que s'est il passé vraiment
dans ce sous sol les inspecteurs ont
sont encore au stade des hypothèses une
chose est sûre tous les corps autopsiés
jusqu'à présent portait les traces
d'injections les signes
démontre qu'un produit puissant
actuellement encore non identifié a été
injectée par injection ou perfusion
pendant que les enquêteurs continuent
leur travail sur le terrain les médecins
légistes ont déjà pu l'identifier
formellement
douze des 23 victimes de chéri mais la
police lance un appel aux familles pour
tenter d'identifier les autres occupants
de la ferme des occupants qui ont
peut-être laissé un testament un
historien spécialisé des sectes a reçu
ce matin par la poste une lettre envoyée
hier de genève une lettre qui
authentifie ray la thèse du suicide
collectif
selon ce courrier la secte se sentait
persécuté notamment au canada où une
enquête policière visait le mouvement il
y a notamment dans le dernier document
intitulé oz épris de justice 8 pages
d'accusation extrêmement violente quand
les autorités la justice la police l
immédiat du québec en allant jusqu'à les
accuser pratiquement d'un assassinat
collectif comme un étrange retournement
d'imputation de ce qui s'est produit
le travail des inspecteurs se poursuit
donc sur plusieurs fronts la police
suisse entend en ce moment même en
qualité de témoin un certain nombre de
personnes proches de la sec tout à fait
autre chose après la tuerie en suisse
d'un adepte de la secte vendent leurs
produits dans le solaire il enquête se
poursuit avec les autopsies des cadavres
et la découverte dans l'un des chalets
incendié d'un pistolet muni d'un
silencieux avec nos aspirations et
valérie gas j'ai chanté camille pilet 68
ans se déplaçait souvent avec une
mallette accroché à son poignet par une
chaîne
considéré comme le numéro trois de la
scène il en était le caissier le porte
valises
quatre jours avant le drame dans cet
hôtel il avait participé en compagnie de
joseph di mambro deux jours elle est de
6 autres convives là l'ultime réunion de
l'exécutif de la secte c'est même lui
qui avait réglé la facture moins d'une
semaine auparavant
camille pilet avait acheté à joseph on
brûle
né de chalets de salvan dans le valais
aucun c'est pourtant ici à cherry dans
un autre suisse que son corps a été
retrouvé il était parmi les vingt-trois
cadavres allongés dans les tranches
appel de la secte certaines victimes
avaient la tête criblé de balles les
policiers détiennent aujourd'hui l'armé
du crime un pistolet de calibre 22 munie
d'un silencieux retrouver à salvan la
découverte de cette dame renforcent
l'une des hypothèses des enquêteurs
selon le ou les meurtriers n'ai vu
d'abord tué 23 personnes à cherry puis
rejoindre salvan par la route pour y
exécuter 25 août fidèles bonne chose a
dit membres et est considéré comme le
vrai patron de la sacd à camille pile
est comme son comptable les deux hommes
étant mort toutes les questions portent
désormais sur le sort de luc jouret le
bourg de l'ordre du temple solaire et il
en lui aussi at il pris la fuite
les autopsies qui se poursuivent à
lausanne devrait bientôt apporter la
réponse bonsoir c'est donc sur le
plateau du vercors que les policiers ont
découvert ce matin les corps de 16
personnes dont trois enfants
recherché depuis une semaine tout laisse
à penser un nouveau suicide collectif
des membres de la secte du temple
solaire une mise en scène macabre tous
les corps sont calcinés
ce qui ralentira l'identification des
victimes le reportage de nos confrères
de grenoble avec le récit de rosendaël
que les corps de 16 membres de la secte
de l'ordre du temple solaire dont trois
enfants ont été retrouvés calcinés
également sur les lieux du drame des
armes de poing et des étuis
correspondant à des armes plus
importante
d'après le procureur il est possible
qu'il y ait des blessures par balles
les corps en tout cas sont dans une
position qui donne à penser que ils ont
été aspergés de liquide inflammable
alors qu'il se trouvait en cercle à 6
ans puisque le
centre du cercle n'est pas trop
enflammée et à la périphérie la trace de
combustion est nette et les corps se
sont affaissés en arrière où il était
déjà dans cette position il est possible
je dis pas probable mais possible
simplement que des armes à feu ont été
utilisées des amendes été retrouvée
parce que des armes se trouvent
effectivement sur les lieux ce lieu une
clairière sur le plateau du vercors une
zone très escarpée difficile d'accès à
9h ce matin c'est donc l'hélicoptère de
la gendarmerie qui donne l'alertent il
ratisse est la région depuis la
découverte hier soir de quatre véhicules
appartenant à des membres de la secte
des membres disparus depuis déjà une
semaine 16 adeptes dont trois enfants
certainement ceux dont les corps ont été
retrouvés aujourd'hui même si aucun n'a
encore été identifié
jeudi dernier les gendarmes de haute
savoie avait déjà retrouvé le véhicule
desdites vuarnet une adepte de la secte
et femme du célèbre skieurs sur le
parking d'une discothèque également
disparu son fils patrick
il avait regretté de ne pas avoir péri
avec ses coreligionnaires lors du
suicide collectif en suisse et au canada
en octobre 94 depuis des membres de la
secte avait expliqué que le prochain
voyage aurait lieu une nuit deux
solstices le solstice d'hiver c'était
hier la secte du temple solaire avait
donc survécu au premier suicide
collectif qui avait fait il ya un peu
plus d'un an 53 morts une nuit de pleine
lune
ce nouveau drame était-il prévisible en
tout cas il pose un certain nombre de
questions
et aujourd'hui les enquêteurs n'excluent
pas que d'autres membres de cette secte
décident à leur tour de faire ce dernier
voyage philippe simon c'est cet homme
luc jouret qui même un an après sa mort
aura poussé ses autres personnes dont
des enfants au suicide collectif
une disparition par le feu comme cela
avait été le cas en octobre 94 dans des
chalets suisses et une autre résidence
au canada
à cette époque 53 ans adepte de l'ordre
du temple solaire choisissait de se
faire entendre par ce qui est pour nous
un massacre pourtant aujourd'hui encore
comme l'expliquent deux policiers
suisses la mort n'avait pas d'importance
pour eux nous avons simplement un
document un effet qui a été retrouvée
d'une personne qui dit que la mort
finalement n'est qu'un passage et
qu'elle se réjouit de retrouver ses
proches
dans un monde ultérieure depuis l'année
dernière on pensait que la secte et ses
membres qui avaient échappé au suicide
s'était dissous il n'en était rien elle
s'absentait presque tous les week-ends
elle avait l'habitude de descendre dans
le sud de la france où elle rejoignait
un médecin qui qui pratiquait la culture
biologique elle était traversée là
dedans c'est ainsi que depuis une
semaine les enquêteurs suisses ont
découvert en interrogeant famille
spécialistes que les adeptes souffrait
de ne pas avoir participé l'année
dernière à la cérémonie macabre de leur
gourou pour l'ordre du temple solaire
comme pour la majorité des sectes la
mort participe pleinement du rituel si
on leur dit que par exemple qu'un médium
va leur dire voilà je suis en
communication avec di mambro et luc
jouret ils nous attendent ils nous ont
préparé une place là où etc
la manipulation est tellement forte
qu'ils iront et suivant une logique
élémentaire mais implacable ils ont
choisi cette forêt du vercors pour leur
cérémonie
c'est le premier procès visant l'ordre
du temple solaire il doit s'ouvrir mardi
devant le tribunal correctionnel de
grenoble un seul prévenu le chef
d'orchestre michel tabachnik dont on ne
sait pas s'il se présentera et 16
cadavres retrouvés dans le vercors la
veille de noël joël bruandet et
guillaume fautrat
23 décembre 95 au lieu-dit la serre du
pasj dans le massif du vercors tôt dans
la matinée les gendarmes découvrent 16
cadavres partiellement calciné 16
personnes disparues depuis une semaine
seize nouvelles victimes de l'ordre du
temple solaire n'ont pas encore été
touchées il se trouve toujours dans la
position que j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
c'est à dire en forme de soleil
disposés en fait en étoile un sac
poubelle sur la tête ils pensaient
s'embarquer pour une nouvelle vie toutes
les victimes dont trois enfants ont reçu
une ou plusieurs balles dans la tête
sur le parking en contrebas de la
clairière quatre voitures immatriculées
en suisse et en france elles
appartiennent aux victimes
mais les indices sont minces les
enquêteurs ont ils à faire à un suicide
collectif
y at il eu intervention extérieure deux
questions au coeur de l'instruction
selon le magistrat chargé de l'enquêté
deux hommes parmi les victimes auraient
été les exécutants du massacre
l'architecte suisse andré frieh et de
lits est cet homme
le français jean-pierre la revanche est
un inspecteur de police après avoir
drogué puis a battu les 14 autres
adeptes
il se serait suicidé d'une balle de 357
magnum
l'ancien champion de ski jean vernet a
perdu sa femme et l'un de ses fils dans
le massacre du vercors avec alain son
autre fils il met en doute les
conclusions de l'instruction et la thèse
du crime en vase clos
six ans après les faits il cherche
toujours à comprendre
il est évident que
il ya un problème de crédibilité il ya
il avait il avait quelque chose mais ses
marges en santé du lait ça ne les emmène
pas si loin ils sont quand même tombés
dans un dans un système qui était qui
était dramatique
un système qui devait leur permettre de
gagner l'étoile sirius rejoindre ce
qu'ils appellent le père par
transformation de la matière le fameux
transit une des nombreuses formules
ésotérique
on retrouvait lors des cérémonies
occultes de la secte les adeptes de
l'ordre du temple solaire se voyait
comme une élite chevaleresque et
mystique
certains affirment et même être la
réincarnation des templiers des 12e et
13e siècles
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
mesdames messieurs bonsoir 23 morts a
chéri le massacre du vercors en rappelle
un autre
quatorze mois plus tôt au canada et en
suisse 53 personnes au total ont trouvé
la mort dans les décombres de ce chalet
du valais les cordes luc jouret médecin
homéopathe belge et du français joseph
di mambro les deux gourous de l'eau ts
pour la justice suisse les acteurs de la
tuerie faisait partie des victimes
elle a donc rendu un non lieu la justice
française
elle a retenu le rôle du chef
d'orchestre suisse michel tabachnik le
juge d'instruction luc fontaine a relevé
que ce proche de 10 membres au centre
sur cette photo était l'auteur de
nombreux textes servant à conditionner
les adeptes des textes où il était déjà
question de sirius le chef d'orchestre
ne sait pas aujourd'hui s'il viendra à
son procès la loi française autorise en
effet depuis le 1er mars à se faire
représenter par son avocat
bouc émissaire ou numéro 3 de l'eau ts
le tribunal s'est donné 15 jours pour
trancher
demain à grenoble devant le tribunal
correctionnel le chef d'orchestre franco
suisse michel tabachnik comparaîtra pour
participation à une association de
malfaiteurs il est le seul accusé dans
ce dossier de l'ordre du temple solaire
dont 74 membres ont péri dans des
suicides collectifs
voyez-les en quête de joël bruandet et y
est on fêtera dans quelques heures ils
seront tous morts
joe di mambro le gourou de l'ordre du
temple solaire a voulu filmer leur
dernier repas autour de la table luc
jouret ici à gauche
[Musique]
tous deux ainsi que leurs convives
drogué seront retrouvés criblés de
balles dans leur chalet en suisse
il devait rejoindre sirius l'étoile la
plus brillante du ciel pour la justice
suisse les deux gourous à l'initiative
de la tuerie sont morts l'instruction
aboutira à un non lieu
mais la justice française elle s'est
intéressée au rôle de michel tabachnik
la semaine dernière le chef d'orchestre
suisse était à paris pour préparer son
procès ah je suis extrêmement écoeuré
extrêmement fâché contre ce procès qui
n'est pas mon procès je tiens à dire
très fort dur je ne sais pas si je vais
me rendre parce qu'il faut pas oublier
que c'est le procès du temps de solaires
et des massacres des d'accord qu'on veut
faire et non pas le mien quant à moi
personnellement je suis suisse j'habite
la suisse j'ai été blanchi par la
justice
donc ce procès à mes yeux aucune raison
d'être par rapport à moi on visera ce
que j'ai à dire vous a présenté comme le
fondateur ou l'un des principaux
animateurs de ce que j'ai à dire cher
monsieur je vous remercie beaucoup
le silence du chef d'orchestre
s'explique l'homme était
incontestablement un proche de joseph di
mambro sur cette photo le voici entouré
du gourou de l'hôtesse et de jocelyne di
mambro pour ce qui ressemble fort à une
cérémonie
une amitié qui date de la fin des années
70 les deux hommes fondent alors à
genève la fondation gol de noël le noyau
dur autour duquel graviteront toutes les
structures de l'ordre du temple solaire
michel tabachnik en est le président
[Musique]
celui qui s'est longtemps défendu d'être
membre de l'hôtesse avait aussi sa
panoplie de templiers comme en témoigne
le registre du tailleur de l'hôtesse qui
confectionnait les caps des adeptes à la
lettre t tabachnick michel taille 4
encolure 52
dans le courant des années 80 le chef
d'orchestre devient une sorte de
prédicateur de la secte lors de voyage
initiatique comme celui ci en egypte il
dispense un enseignement où il est
notamment question de transmutation par
la carbonisation ou encore de sirius ce
sont précisément ces écrits que le juge
d'instruction lui reproche par ses
textes
michel tabachnik aurait fait progresser
chez les adeptes ce que le juge appelle
une dynamique de mort même si
l'instruction a démontré qu'il n'avait
aucun lien direct avec le massacre du
vercors
[Musique]